good morning Hank it's Tuesday this
video is about my mental health but I
want to say here at the outset that I am
NOT a psychologist and that in general I
think we should listen to experts when
it comes to mental health and also when
it comes to other things but I can only
speak to my personal experience okay so
it seems to me that the stuff happening
way down inside of us is difficult to
talk about partly because those
experiences aren't really accessible by
the senses you can't usually see or hear
psychic pain and it's difficult to
describe without simile or metaphor like
I might say that it feels like there's a
void inside of me or like my insides are
twisted or like my brain is on fire I
can say what it's like more than I can
say what it is so I have
obsessive-compulsive disorder which is
mostly seen in the popular imagination
as being about like excessive hand
washing or neatness or whatever because
those are things you can see you know
they're not like the formless insensate
horrors of psychic pain they're
behaviors that you can like portray in a
movie but for me at least there's a
reason the obsessive comes before the
compulsive in the name so I experienced
these obsessive thought spirals in which
intrusive thoughts that is like thoughts
that I don't want to have that seemed to
come from outside of me sort of hijack
my consciousness now everyone has known
some version of not being able to choose
their thoughts like after you lose
someone you may find yourself thinking
about them all the time you may see a
sunset and think about seeing a sunset
with that person or you open a car door
and remember driving with them etc but
for me these obsessive thoughts spirals
happen all the time and they can take
over for days or weeks or months like I
might worry out of nowhere that my food
is contaminated or somehow poisoned and
then suddenly that will be the only
thought I'm able to think the thought I
might are thinking or distracting myself
from all the time and when that gets bad
I can lose all control over my thoughts
for an extended period of time to the
extent that I can't follow what's
happening in a TV show or read a book
this is exhausting of course but it's
also kind of terrifying because one I
can't stop being scared of the thing I'm
scared about and two if I can't choose
my thoughts and I am at least in part
made out of those thoughts then am I
actually the captain of this ship I call
myself and the more you think about that
at least for me the more it becomes sort
of the premise for a horror movie right
so the compulsive behaviors I use to
cope with these obsessive thought
spirals repeatedly checking my food for
contamination for instance or spending
hours googling what will happen to me if
I eat moldy
those are Fermi ways of trying to
comfort and calm myself like I'm not
checking over and over again to be
eccentric or whatever I'm doing it
because I cannot stop obsessing over the
fear that I might have eaten living mold
and I will do whatever I can not to be
strangled by that thought mental illness
is highly stigmatized in our culture but
it is also sometimes romanticized we see
TV shows where in order to catch a
terrorist a mentally ill person must go
off their meds or we see obsessive
detectives whose obsessiveness allows
them to crack cases that others couldn't
that kind of thing might be true to some
people's experiences but it hasn't been
true to mine like I don't feel like my
mental illness has any superpower side
effects in fact when I'm stuck inside a
thought spiral I find it very difficult
to observe like anything outside of
myself I become a terrible detective so
when I started the book that has become
Turtles all the way down I wanted to
like try to find form and expression for
this way down nonsense Oreo experience
of living inside of thought spirals the
book is fictional totally fictional but
it began for me with thinking about what
it would be like to be this one
particular sixteen year old girl
hazel Holmes who's trying to be a good
daughter and a good friend and a good
student and maybe even a good detective
while also living with terrifying
thought spirals that she cannot see or
hear but that are nonetheless very real
so like that's a bit of an introduction
to the story and how I came to write it
I also want to say to anyone out there
concerned about their mental health
please please seek help I've put some
resources in the doobly-doo below I know
it can be difficult to get effective
treatment but there is hope even if your
brain tells you there isn't the vast
majority of mental illness is treatable
and lots of people with chronic mental
health problems have fulfilling and
vibrant lives hank dftba i will see you
on Friday